gang gang buzz buzz guys uh I guess
confession
so me and my girl been trying to
conceive for uh
quite a while now a little does she know
that I've had a vasectomy dude get out
of color
or should I just keep on practicing oh
my God let me know God he's a monster
wait hold on for a while so you've been
together for a bit she doesn't know
about this it's this guy
hey dude this guy's priorities are and
he's just like telling us like hey guy
well first of all
wait
I want to talk to this guy like is there
more he doesn't want to have kids man
but don't have kids and he doesn't want
to wear a condom you think that's what
it is yeah I mean I guess it's also
[ __ ] up though because if I don't know
how old his lady is but if she's under
the impression that you can have kids
and just not happening she's gonna think
it's her it's so [ __ ] up yeah yeah you
got to tell her immediately and he can
reverse the vasectomy yeah true true you
can right he's a monster also don't give
a sec to me right no don't get a
vasectomy I feel like that's super I I
don't know not natural I was talking to
a guy I mean yeah his Discord there you
date a girl with fake tits you know what
I mean I'm saying this is also a guy
perspective you know a girl I mean it's
not natural also to take you know some
hormonal birth control that's messing
with your system every single day you
have to take it just so you don't get
pregnant Eric shut the [ __ ] up
what are we trying to do here man Eric
with your girls too much man you know
what dude you're being a [ __ ] [ __ ]
right now
I saw this great
thing for my chick and it said like you
know
uh I she goes I took a pill he won't
take a pill so I can get a dog but I
took a pill every day this week yeah wow
that's a hell of a tick tock
that's what I'm saying yeah the guy's
like guys going I don't want it yeah
yeah no I don't know I want to take a
pill for your dog yeah but I agree with
that guy yeah
uh no I I think that uh yeah I don't
know if it's like I was talking to a guy
and I was like
um just a normal guy yeah nobody he was
another comedian and I and he has a
vasectomy and uh and I said you know
he's married and uh his kids and stuff
and I was like so you gotta vasect me
because you didn't want more kids and he
was like yeah I don't want more kids and
um honestly like I was like it just it's
not worth it to me like to me like what
if you do want more kids number one
number two
surgery you know what I mean it take it
takes like a month to yeah sit on a bag
of peas they slice just a lot and then
you can ghosts and I said and I said to
me it's just not worth it just like pull
out you know or whatever and he was like
oh he said uh the idea of
um you know completing in my wife
um God raw well you got to do it
clinical sometimes you don't [ __ ]
restrict it on YouTube
um completing in my wife was this was
this Dr Drew yeah the idea of completing
in your wife he said is Dr Phil
Dr Phil is that you did Dr Phil I said
Dr Drew oh got it okay that's okay
so um
so both bust enough he said he said for
the rest of my life brings me so much
joy and I was like oh okay probably to
both of them fair enough yeah fair
enough then yeah I think it's a guy
thing yeah I like this oh yeah